[Música]
hola en este vídeo presentaremos como
los profesores pueden configurar sus
clases y listas de estudiantes primero
inicie sesión en khan academy después
haz clic en el botón de navegación y
luego en el panel del profesor en esa
página encontrarás los recursos para
agregar y organizar tus clases
[Música]
para crear una clase ve al panel del
profesor selecciona la opción clases y
luego haz clic en el botón agregar una
clase en la esquina derecha de la
pantalla te recomendamos crear clases
separadas para cada uno de tus grupos
por ejemplo si enseñas a un grupo del
sexto grado en la escuela siglo 21 te
recomendamos incluir esta información en
el nombre de tu clase en kanaker y lo
importante es elegir un nombre que te
permita organizar fácilmente tu panel
del profesor y que se te facilita el
acceso si ya utilizas google classroom
puedes importar tus clases con todos los
estudiantes directamente a canacar en
pero si ese no es tu caso
comienzo por darle un nombre a tu clase
ahora vamos a elegir uno o más cursos
para tu clase
desplázate hacia abajo para ver la lista
completa de cursos disponibles puedes
elegir el curso de un componente
curricular como física o biología o una
asignatura específica como aritmética
además puedes seleccionar contenido de
matemáticas por año escolar
mucho contenido y no te preocupes si
cambias de opinión
puedes editar el nombre de tu clase y
los cursos en cualquier momento ahora
veremos cómo agregar a tus estudiantes a
una clase hay diferentes maneras de
hacer esto a través de google classroom
con un código o creando cuentas
especiales de khan academy para tus
estudiantes
si tienes google claro te recomendamos
que lo utilices para importar tus listas
también puedes invitar a tus alumnos
utilizando el código de clase comparte
el código con tus estudiantes y pídeles
que ingresen a la plataforma hagan clic
en la pestaña profesores e ingresen el
código que les proporciona este de esa
manera ingresarán directamente a tu
clase si tus estudiantes no tienen
cuentas de correo electrónico tu puedes
crear cuentas de caná khadem y para
ellos pero recuerda antes de hacerlo
debes tener en cuenta que cada academia
asume que tú cuentas con el permiso de
los padres o tutores de estudiantes
menores de 18 años
américa o 13 años en los eeuu selecciona
la opción crear cuentas para tus alumnos
al crear estas cuentas que llamamos
cuentas especiales
la plataforma genera automáticamente
nombres de usuario y contraseñas puedes
editar las contraseñas para tus
estudiantes según tus preferencias
te recomendamos descargar la lista
completa con información de inicio de
sesión y que la guardes en tus archivos
por si necesitas consultarlos en el
futuro pero ten cuidado sólo podrás
descargar esta lista en este momento
aunque si omita la descarga no te
preocupes también recibirás un correo
electrónico con toda esta información
para mantener tu lista de estudiantes
actualizada selecciono una clase y en el
menú vertical selecciona la pestaña
estudiantes ahí podrás añadir o eliminar
alumnos y clases si un nuevo estudiante
se unirá a tu clase haz clic en el botón
agregar nuevos estudiantes y elige el
proceso que más
si alguno de tus alumnos es transferido
a otra clase pero sigue siendo tu
estudiante selecciona su nombre y haz
clic en la opción agregar a la clase
desde aquí podrás ponerlo en la clase
que le corresponde
después de eso podrás eliminarlo de la
clase original usando eliminar la clase
si ya no eres profesor de un alumno
selecciona su nombre y haz clic en
terminar tutoría eso eliminará al
estudiante de todas tus listas y ya no
tendrás acceso a sus reportes de
desempeño si deseas borrar toda la lista
de una clase al final del año escolar
simplemente seleccione el cuadro en la
primera línea y luego haz clic en
terminar tutoría una recomendación
puedes editar el nombre que se muestra
para cualquiera de tus estudiantes al
desplazarte sobre el nombre que deseas
cambiar y hacer clic en la opción edita
el nombre que se muestra ingresa un
nuevo nombre guarda o presiona enter y
listo este cambio no aparecerá para el
estudiante y no cambiará los datos que
utiliza para ingresar a la plataforma
sí
para otros ajustes en tus clases ingresa
al apartado de configuración podrás
editar el nombre de la clase cambiar el
curso eliminar la clase actualizar la
sincronización de los estudiantes con
google classroom y registrarte para
recibir un informe semanal del
rendimiento de tus estudiantes
[Música]
para obtener más información sobre khan
academy visita nuestro centro de ayuda y
consulta nuestra sección de preguntas
frecuentes
[Música]